i've already bought one property
recently which is a very funny story
actually to tell
go what happened
i was watching auctions and i just
thought
you know what i'm mean property i might
as well just learn
how does auction work so um
i went and burned the wolf i was
watching the properties i think i was
this was the
200 year property i was watching
i noticed that people can beat on a
property 30 40 times you know or even 10
times
i just thought let me click a button to
say a deep beat as well
you know someone who outbid me of course
yeah
and soon after i click the button i got
a text message to say you won
wow yeah when did this happen
this was november 2020. so just a few
months back now
and yeah much how much did you buy it
for it was 24 000.
24 000 where did you get the money from
we had we didn't have any money to be
honest
it was such a very funny story and
so there was no money at all to pay for
the property
so i approached my bank i just thought
oh well
because of the the property that we live
in it does have equity
but we refine we had um remortgaged
um a bit but they when i applied for for
the
um extra loan they said we can only give
you six thousand pounds
i was like six thousand pounds which
will only cover the depositors the
property it won't cover everything
yeah yeah so um i used
a a financing loan a preaching loan
okay so yeah use the preaching loan and
they they did a second attachment into
the property and then
uh so you took a six thousand pound line
for the deposit
no i didn't take it yeah i just said no
did they give you the whole money to buy
it yeah they gave me the whole money wow
they obviously thought it was a good
deal they thought yeah but they attached
the um the lawn into our current
property where we live
oh right yeah yeah i think because they
they knew it a bit
and it's worth a lot more so you bought
it for 24 grand
yeah and you're going to be have you
started renovations yet
we've finished renovating are you
finished yeah we've finished this
only a dark horse aren't you all right
so you've bought 24
you've renovated it and how much is it
worth now
it's worth about 43 000 pounds and how
much did you spend on it
we spent just over 2 000 pounds
only 2 000 yeah wow hold on
where is this house it's in uh bishop
auckland
oh i know the area okay very cheap area
yeah okay
so you bought it for 24 you spent 2
000 on it yes you spent 26 000 in total
it's now at 43
000. so what's the plan the plan is to
refinance it
yeah one is the refinance and get the
all the money out and a little bit extra
and then use it possibly for another
rent to rent
when more profit comes up and wow so
that's another problem
pull all your money out deal yeah
absolutely incredible so you're going
through the refinance now
yeah we're going to start the
refinancing absolutely brilliant
how does it feel then to just be like i
mean to be buying houses like that
that's just crazy it is crazy and never
happens
accident it it's called
a serendipity moment where you
accidentally
get something really good by accident
yeah yeah
i i still can't believe it today that is
crazy that's from free knowledge from
you
oh wow it's great and and that's the
thing the crash course is free
you know there is no catches and i think
a lot of people are very skeptical
about rent to rents buying cheap houses
about the free training um you know what
would you say to people that were
that were even watching this video and
thinking i don't believe it
this sounds too good to be true what
would you say
i would say to them i'm here today
i'm doing property i never thought i'll
be here
doing any rent to rent if you have any
ideas about getting into property
start now time will not wait for you
yeah and i would advise you to
go for training and whether it's buying
a book
read get more information and
take action yeah massive wise words